la unión europea entonces decidió
conjuntamente infligir golpes duros
afectar a las personas y aceptó esto
será completado con medidas
gubernamentales
esta mañana solicite algunos trabajos en
particular sobre bienes personales y
alguna serie de personalidades para
complementar estas medidas estas
sanciones también afectarán al régimen
bielorruso que es cómplice de estas
acciones y esto nos lo muestran las
evoluciones recientes de las últimas
semanas el segundo elemento sobre el que
decidimos o dos grupos es el apoyo a
ucrania una ayuda económica sin
precedentes a ucrania fue definida por
nosotros adoptamos un paquete de ayudas
macrofinancieras de dos mil millones de
euros y éstas seguirá avanzando y se
movilizarán todos los medios financieros
y materiales francia contribuir a este
esfuerzo complementario con 300 millones
de euros para la economía ucraniana y
estamos dispuestos a continuar
despachando un material militar
apoyo a la población como se lo dije al
presidente es el
tercer elemento es el de la tradición de
los europeos es de unos hombros
protección militar
entraré mañana en detalles durante la
cumbre que os tendremos con la otan
francia seguirá en su poder
asegurar a los aliados
y reforzando su participación en la
política de vándalos prácticos en marzo
y acelerando también su despliegue hacia
ruano más allá de esto
pero estaremos siempre al lado de
nuestros aliados y con era infalible
protección económica también con la
adopción rápida de medidas para hacer
frente a esta crisis de excepcional
gravedad particularmente en cuanto a los
precios de la energía para que los
ciudadanos europeos y nuestras empresas
estén totalmente protegen del uso y
protección de nuestra democracia de
nuestras opiniones públicas en el
contexto y acaba de ser recordado con
las iniciativas suplementarias que
tomaremos en materia de cibernética en
materia de lucha contra la
desinformación
que está siendo propagada por las redes
sociales y varios puntos de propaganda
rusa en el suelo europeo y para concluir
recordaré lo que dijo al presidente
michel a quien agradezco todas las
iniciativas que ha tenido esos últimos
días y semanas y también a lo que dijo
la presidenta von der leyen
creo que hemos demostrado plenamente la
necesidad que tiene europa de acelerar
su agenda de soberanía
en los tiempos trágicos de la historia
se han regresado la guerra está en
nuestro suelo
si fuera necesario demostrar que europa
no es simplemente un mercado de
consumidores sino una potencia que debe
pensar su independencia energética su
transición climática por sí misma que
debe pensar en una europa de la defensa
capaz de proteger sus fronteras ya sus
ciudadanos y de proyectarse hacia sus
aliados entre otras cosas y por supuesto
también una soberanía tecnológica la
guerra que estamos viviendo nos lo
demuestra de manera cruel por eso
continuaremos con la agenda templar eso
estos últimos meses y estos últimos años
para acelerarlo porque ya podemos
demostrar que en los tiempos trágicos
que estamos viviendo sólo podemos volver
a hacer la potencia muchas gracias